hi everyone my name's Andrew Campbell
I'm a data analyst at a crowdsourced
hedge fund in Boston called quanto pian
and I'm gonna talk a little bit about
how I solved a problem that I was
presented with as a data analyst using
this really cool tool called ipython
widgets I'm gonna say that quant opine
is a crowdsource hedge fund I mean that
we're a free platform for building trade
building deploying researching and
discussing algorithmic trading
strategies and so anyone can come to our
site in for free code of an algorithm in
Python back-tested on thirteen years of
minute level historical pricing data
deployed on the market and then they can
enter our contest but the really cool
part and the part that we're working
really hard to expand right now is this
hedge fund part of the business where
we're looking through this database of
trades and historical performance on
these algorithms and trying to find the
best algorithm writers and so we can't
look at the algorithm code so we're left
looking at like I said this exhaust data
just to see who are the people we want
to invite to be part of our fund those
individuals invite them to be a part of
our fund and say hey we love what you're
doing we'd love to give you a cut of the
profits you generate as a part of as a
part of our company and so as a data
science team we're faced with this kind
of seven hundred thousand to ten problem
where we've got all these algorithms in
our point-in-time database and we need
to filter down and find which are the
absolute best that we want to invest in
and what that means is that we can
automate this largely automate this
process 99% of what comes to the
platform we can filter out based on just
some like pretty tight filters on back
test performance what's left over we let
sit for six months where it accumulates
six months or maybe sometimes longer
depending on the characteristics of the
algorithm of out-of-sample data data to
which the algorithm rather could not
have possibly over fit their strategy
because it had not occurred yet and then
after that out of sight out of sample
data accumulates we put the we put the
algo through another set of performance
filters and then we're left with a
smaller collection that we have to parse
through manually and this kind of brings
us to like a
theme and data science that not
everything can be automated
sometimes there's manual steps you know
data has to be digested in a graphical
form in a way that a human can look and
say oh it's trading these names and like
this you know period is worrisome that
we haven't yet been able to codify I
think we would love to be able to make
this an automatic crank that we just
turn but we're not quite there yet and
so we needed something to facilitate
this manual step this last step of
saying what do we want to actually
include in our fund and so for the data
digestion part of this problem we built
this awesome this awesome
Python module called pi folio which if
you were around for Jessa's talk earlier
she gave an awesome crash course in what
pi folio has to offer for those of you
who weren't it's you pass in a back test
it's actually platform agnostic in that
it's an open source project you can pass
in any form of returns or positions data
or the the form that it's expecting and
it'll generate all these beautiful plots
that that tell you about that
performance the algorithm of our time
what it's draw downs were and then a
bunch of really cool stuff on Bayesian
analysis comparing the in and out of
sample periods so we built this awesome
tool but we still were left with this
bookkeeping problem we needed to
remember which algorithms do we write
when were they written how do we keep
track of them who are these authors and
this this this bookkeeping problem we we
like many fledgling projects we started
with a Google Doc and you're all
familiar with this it was great at first
we're plugging and playing we're grading
strategies everything looks good then we
get to about 45 algos and things start
to go downhill really fast it's very
hard to keep track of you know 20
character long random of like [ __ ] IDs
you know in a way that you're not going
to absolutely lose your mind and so
there was a lot of cutting and pasting
involved here a lot of messy
unstructured data and so we knew we
needed something a little bit more
productized
luckily we had already had this really
cool Jupiter hub data science
environment that we were using to do all
of our analysis
jupiter hub is a multi-user server
system for the jupiter AKA ipython
notebook platform it's awesome because
we leverage the computing power of AWS
like we're running on some huge beefy
instance in the cloud we don't have to
worry about my laptop fast enough to
crunch this 20 gigs of data and we can
easily distribute what we create with
one another as a team you know
everything flows from user to user
really easily if you're interested we do
my colleague Thomas wiki has written an
awesome docker file that allows you to
quickly spin up a Jupiter hub
environment complete with the whole PI
data stack and so we started to use this
this Jupiter hub environment as our
replacement Google Doc this is going to
be the platform off of which we're gonna
build our bookkeeping system and so I
started by reading some simple functions
I set up a Postgres database and started
writing functions in sequel alchemy that
would simply just take out gorillas my
DS grades comments put them in the
database query them out of the database
super simple I threw all these these
functions in a notebook handed it off to
my team and the results were so so as we
found out there's a lot that can go
wrong when you just give someone an
undocumented function in a big messy
notebook are you my users weren't
necessarily entering their names in a
uniform format they weren't necessarily
entering a uniform set of grades which
was really a big problem when at the end
of the day we want to say all right
which of the algorithms fall in these
four buckets and we've got people using
different grading systems some are using
ABC others a a minus B plus and so I
needed something that would force a
convention upon our data science team
and allow allow us to like very strictly
enforce some rules when it came to
grading and we also needed this this new
grading bookkeeping platform to be
something that we could iterate on
really fast to my knowledge no one has
really ever crowd-sourced a hedge fund
if you go on like Instructables and look
up how to crowdsource a hedge fund
nothing comes up so
we were making this up as we go this
process is always evolving and we need
something that we can quickly edit and
turn around say how we want to change
how we're doing this I need to see it in
the grading workflow in two hours so the
answer to that was widgets by widgets
also known as just plain old widgets are
the interactive arm of the Jupiter
project they used to be a part of the
ipython project that you would import
them under the ipython module they've
this since been separated out into their
own their own repo and they play really
nicely with the Jupiter current Jupiter
environment but so far they've largely
been focused on digesting data but and
what I mean by that is you throw a
widget in your notebook and it allows
you to change the axes on a graph or
choose what data is being plot plotted
it's awesome it brings users closer to
their data but I thought why not take
this a step further and actually build a
fully blown application something that
we can use every day to do our jobs with
widgets and so that is what I did but
first a little bit on how they work and
I apologize that I am kind of doing some
hand waving here widgets are awesome the
whole of Jupiter project is very complex
and takes care of all this crazy stuff
in the background for you it's like
totally awesome if you're interested you
should go and dig into the source code
it's all on github all open source but
widgets at their essence use this thing
called the comms API short for
communications to synchronize a Python
model in the back end and that back end
could be a server in the cloud or it
could be your local machine with a
javascript view what's being viewed in
your browser they handle all sorts of
WebSocket complexity for us asynchronous
calls they run really fast so just take
that and say wow widgets are great thank
you for doing all the stuff for me
widgets first some basics there's two
basic components that made up my
microphone
the first was forms forms are some sort
of input device they can be they can
come in many forms integer this here we
have an integer field a drop-down menu
and area to enter comments
and you can access the value of a widget
by calling for certain attributes on on
the on that widget object so this is
very object-oriented it'll make sense to
you if you've spent any time dealing
with Python super easy to implement and
best of all if you're like me and you
don't know anything really about
front-end development all that front-end
is just magically taken care of for you
so all you're dealing with this Python
and it's in the same environment that
you've already been doing all your data
science and the next important component
are buttons buttons unlike forms are
stateless meaning that they're not
automatically synchronized with the
Python model in the backend so in order
to make them stateful we have to set an
on-click function you do that very
similarly to how you'd set an on-click
in JavaScript and this makes the the
button stateful and that it set the
listener it says when I'm clicked in
this front-end send a calm to the
backend and execute this function and so
quickly you can start to string together
widgets and build and build out your
form that you're going to make that
you're gonna use for your application a
really handy tool that comes with the
widgets project are H boxes and V boxes
horizontal boxes and vertical boxes you
can use these to put together widgets in
a way that looks like a real form you'd
see on a web site if you just start
displaying them they'll just appear in
order and it looks a little bit messy I
should note that the display function
which comes with ipython is what renders
the JavaScript you in the front end so
you need to call that to say set up this
this javascript view so that so that our
user can interact with it and that also
takes care of a bunch of the
synchronization synchronization
complexity behind the scenes you can
also edit certain features of widgets
using those same attributes that you
were using to call for the value of the
widgets before so stuff like the Marjane
font size they all recognize this from
from your basic knowledge of CSS
and once you have that you can then so
now we have our input we've got our form
and now we have to think about how do we
digest data so a really useful tool that
I'm a huge fan of is cue grid it's
something that one of our developers at
quanto viens Scott Sanderson who's
actually also speaking here tomorrow
developed and it's a tool for you for
digesting large amounts of data frame in
a notebook in a really fast way and so
it's based on the slick grid slicker ejs
JavaScript grid view and runs runs in
Python so you can just pass it something
like it or you pass it a data frame and
it will render it as a sortable
filterable grid it's really cool because
it is aware of the types of columns so
if you have a date column it can be
filtered like it's a date column and
similarly with an integer column
filtered like an integer or a text
column filtered with searching on text
so this is particularly useful for us as
we're looking at creating algorithms and
we want to say okay we've done all this
grading now end of the month what are
our A's so I want to see my a z' and I
want to see the most recent ones and Q
grid allows us to do that a really slick
slick way so now combining Q grid with
our form we've got this awesome
beginnings of an actual application this
is more than just choosing what we're
going to plot this is we are going to
use this every day to process data and
store it in a database but if you're
like me that isn't quite enough you want
to know a little bit more how the
widgets work and see if we can become
like a little bit more of a power user
and so I'm gonna talk about two custom
custom widget widget modifications as
examples of how you pass things back and
forth between the front and back end the
first is that we're gonna make it so
that when we select a row and queue grid
it's gonna pass the algo ID of that row
to our form so instead of having to copy
paste that algo ID we're gonna click the
row and it's automatically going to
appear in our form and the second is
that when we submit a new grade instead
of having
load the data from our database in queue
grid to get that grade populated in the
table we're going to submit the grade to
the database but also pass that grade
directly to the view so it can just
update it right away in in the cue grid
so first let's talk about the front to
back
this is JavaScript it's not as produced
Python code but you'll have to do you
all have to deal with it I apologize to
a lot of this is a lot of this is
omitted just for the sake of getting
this all on one slide and so here we're
defining a cue Bridget a cue grid view
and we're extending upon the Dom widgets
view base class and this is awesome
because the Dom would just view base
class comes with all these handy
functions that allow us to do things
like pass data back and forth between
the front and back end in ipython and so
here we are we're setting a listener
onmousedown which is a which is a
function that comes with slick grid and
saying okay if slick grid is clicked now
we want to execute this function that's
going to take the selected row pull out
the data put it in a message and send
that message to the to the back end and
so that that will send method comes with
the Dom widgets view base class and
makes it really easy to do to do that
kind of communication you'll also notice
here that there's stuff that looks like
this dot dollar sign l which that is a
also another really handy built-in
feature that allows you to like quickly
access the jQuery object that is the cue
grid container and as well as stuff like
this model yet which allows us to pull
attributes directly from the Python
model into the JavaScript view and so
once we've sent our message away it
flies through space to the Python model
where it's received by a custom listener
that we set up within our Python queue
grid widget class
and you'll notice again that here this
clot this cue grid widget class inherits
from the widgets Dom widgets base class
that's also again really important in
that it inherits all these really
helpful at your really helpful methods
and attributes that allow to sync with
the JavaScript view importantly this
view module and view name are required
fields when you're building a custom
widget here we're telling we're telling
the Python back-end this is where you
should look for our front-end and also
this is the name of our front-end so
that they can get they can get in sync
this little sync equals true is part of
the trail it's library and trail it's
our typesafe attributes that you can add
to modules they're particularly useful
in widgets for some for because they
take this sync argument and that a lot
that says when this attribute changes
send it to the to the view make it
available to the view when something
changes so here we're setting up this
custom listener handle keyword message
receiving our message if it's of the
type we expect then pull out the row
data pull out the algo ID from the row
data and set it to that selected ID
trait tlit which will be able to access
from a variety of places and so now when
we click in our cue grid that trait lit
the the value of algo ID becomes
available in the in the Python model
it's set to the sets of the value of
that selected ID trait lit and we're
using this link function which comes
with trail it's to link the value of
that selected ID to the value of this
field here of the algo ID field and so
this can be used for a number of things
there's a lot of really cool
applications we that involve linking
together widgets highly recommend going
checking out some of the examples in the
I pi widgets github repo and so now that
we've done that we're comfortable
syncing things from front to back let's
talk a little bit about syncing things
from back to
and so if you remember our second goal
was to as we submit a new grade make it
so that that grade will be not only put
in the database but but automatically
populated in our front-end and to do
that we've I'm writing this custom
function inside of our cue grid widgets
model and this if you're gonna be
writing good reusable code you would
probably write something a little bit
more generalizable that would you know
take a take indexes rather than taking
graders and grades but for the purpose
of this demonstration and this custom
widget we've written something that
takes care of everything for us so we
pass it an algo ID a grater and a grade
it'll find it'll look in the data frame
that's associated with the cue grid find
the row and column indices and then pass
those indices along with the grade and a
label for this message to the front end
and so then this flies to the front
where it is received by a custom message
handler that we are defining this small
dot on is how you define a custom
message or a custom handler in a in in a
widget and this message colon custom is
backbone.js syntax and it's saying if a
message of this type custom is received
then send it to this handle message
function so once we receive this custom
message it goes to a handle message
function where it's processed we confirm
is of the type we're expecting and we're
using slick grid which as you remember
couger is an extension upon the
JavaScript project slick read to get the
cell nodes so this is the cell node in
this case is going to return a jQuery
object that points to this is the exact
bit on our table that we're gonna want
to update so we pull out that jQuery
object set the inner text to our new
value and we're in business
but before that can work we need to know
who our user is right I like I said
before I don't want people just typing
in their name that's prone to err
the more we can abstract away from the
user and just let them do their job the
better and so we're gonna use this handy
little feature of the ipython project
that allows you to access bash commands
directly from the notebook so those are
you familiar with ipython will know that
you can write bang and then a bash
command it'll execute that command as if
it's a terminal command and send you
back the response so in this function
get user and we're going to use that
functionality to pull from our Jupiter
hub server who the logged in user is and
we're gonna do that by first defining a
dictionary of user names of bash of our
Jupiter hub user names mapped to user
names in the context of the grading
notebook and then calling bang echo and
then the global variable user and the
response should be who is the user of
this of the current session of this
Jupiter hub server and so we get our
response pull it in
pass it to this dictionary and get out
the user in the context of our grading
notebook and then within our new grade
function we can use that to get up get
our user as well as accessing the
selected grade and algo ID from the
fields in our form write those to the
database if everything goes all right
then update the grade in queue grid
using that custom function we just
defined and we should be good to go we
just have to set it to be the on click
function of that grade button that's
already a part of that nested form
another really cool trick that you can
use to make your applications look
professional is hiding the code cells I
think this should be a default feature
in the ipython progr so if any of you
are ipython Jupiter to vet devs out
there like this feature request but you
can really easily add this yourselves
and by just creating a button widget
that will execute some JavaScript that
just hides the cells hides the inputs
and so by clicking this guy
you can get rid of all your code cells
which will just leave you with your
widgets or whatever displays or cue
grids you have in the page and it just
looks like a looks like an ordinary
ordinary application page another really
cool display gem that has helped me a
lot in creating more
professional-looking applications right
on this I pipe in environment is to
change the width of the code cells by
making them wider this is especially
helpful when you're working with cue
grid because it allows you to render
your columns a little bit wider so you
can more easily see what's going on in
your data so that's another cool trick
and here again we're using the display
function that comes with ipython as well
as the HTML function which just allows
you to execute arbitrary HTML in the
notebook and we're just passing in this
style tag saying set the width of the of
the code container to be 90% of the of
the screen and so now we have our final
application with our updating value and
we can set the grids straight from
straight into the view and I've uploaded
this notebook to github if you're
interested in got a little cut off there
but if you're interested in any of this
kind of stuff check that out there's
also a ton of resources on the ipython
ipython repo as well as the eye pie
widgets repo so yeah thank you
yeah yeah that's a good question um you
know I haven't written anything that
will automatically execute a notebook
when it opens I think sometimes that's
considered to be kind of a no-no in like
development to just arbitrarily run code
so sue someone loads a page but the run
all cells button within ipython you can
go in the top nav bar and click run all
cells and then hopefully that would just
set everything up for your user and you
can also have it execute that hide code
cells functions so that when they do run
all the cells it hides everything and
makes it look pretty clean I can show
you what one of the additions of what
we're working with looks right now look
right now so this is a fun grading
notebook that I developed and here these
are all fields where where you can enter
filters so you can query out algorithms
by different performance metrics and in
this notebook I just have it configured
so that when someone runs all the cells
automatically hides the code cells and
gives you and gives you a nice clean
output it's also nice that we can
integrate this directly with PI folio
there's no need for the for the grader
to bounce back and forth between
different notebooks that's another
beauty of of doing everything right from
your superhub environment is that just
bring all your tools in one place no
reason to write a custom flask app that
has to pull in from all these different
sources it's already all there
cool thank you guys
you